les époques les dangers grande aventure
les a même si c'est les bobettes
temporaires
les POP est temporelle continue nos
héros sont toujours à la recherche du
docteur Simon le père d'irdyris vous les
avions laissés dans un bateau en feu au
large de l'île de la Réunion en 1710
prêt à se faire découper par l'abuse le
célèbre pirate sanguinaire après tout il
a une hache il faut bien qu'il s'en
servent
pourquoi vous voulez nous tuer on se
connaît même pas moi les gens c'est pas
compliqué soit il me donne de l'argent
pour que je tue quelqu'un soit très
binaire comme conception de la vie
j'aime beaucoup on est plutôt de la
première catégorie
pour 5000 pièces je te kiffes vous
voulez on cherche un scientifique ah il
y a un scientifique qui arrive il y a
pas longtemps
tu es
mais vous savez ce que je fais
aujourd'hui je comprends pas
absolument vous allez écouter à ma hache
elle a le goût de la mort
si vous avez raison on veut le tuer ce
scientifique
vous vous entendez si mal que ça c'est
un stratagème il nous mène à lui et hop
on se téléporte
mille tout à l'heure c'était
non ce bateau est en feu on peut
peut-être négocier plus tard
[Musique]
voici mon bateau en route c'est vous qui
avez mis le feu à l'autre bateau ouais
pourquoi donc parce que je suis un
pirate tout le monde et jamais le feu
vous pourriez pas prendre le bateau et
le revendre plutôt
accrochez-vous j'ouvre les voiles on est
pas très loin
[Musique]
la buse
spéciale pour vous une mission que seul
un grand pirate peut remplir je suis le
plus grand des pirates vous ne menez à
ce scientifique mais vous n'allez pas le
tuer tout de suite vous voulez que je le
torture vous commencez à me plaire vous
le tuerez quand l'un d'entre nous dira
le signal et ce signal ce sera le mot
voilà pomme facile vous le tuez pas tant
que l'un d'entre nous n'a pas dit pomme
Audrey j'attends à des lieux à la ronde
je vais pas le louper Eliott pourquoi
pas c'est mon mot de passe interne ah tu
es pas un super sécurisé personne ne
veut pirater une machine à café
sa phrase 7000 pièces direction la
taverne je sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai
l'impression que tout ça est un très
mauvais plan
[Musique]
le scientifique vient dans cette taverne
tous les jours en début de soirée on
pourra pas le rater tout le monde
l'insulte quand il entre
bonsoir qu'est-ce que je vous sers du
rhum pour ces gars-là et pour moi alors
de l'eau pour moi j'ai assez bu au
Moyen-Âge
je me retiens depuis deux jours j'aime
pas faire caca sur mon bateau et touchez
pas à mon verre vous savez ce que je
fais aux gens qui touchent à mon verre
j'imagine que
je pensais et voilà les trois robes et
un verre d'eau pour le courage merci
iris c'est fou toutes tes aventures
qu'on vit ensemble on a frôlé la mort et
c'est dans ces moments-là qu'on réalise
que l'amour c'est le vrai qu'on a
complètement oublié de te déposer chez
toi
on a une mission je veux rencontrer ton
père qui est probablement un grand homme
non je t'arrête tout de suite mon père
n'est pas un grand homme c'est un homme
qui a jamais levé le nez
de cerder un dessin que je lui avais
fait quand j'étais à gauche je suis
parti une semaine sans le prévenir quand
je suis rentré il m'a juste dit tu as
passé une bonne soirée d'accord
tu vois je trouve ça un peu lâche
d'essayer d'en partir
moi si tu me faisais un dessin je
l'accrocherai au frigo parce que c'est
aussi ça un couple c'est aussi des
petites attentions
on vérifie il est attiré par la taille
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est pas du tout mon père
identification c'est le scientifique
Isaac Newton
est-ce que j'aime pas faire
[Applaudissements]
à vrai dire vous m'avez projeté au sol
donc vous avez exercer une force en plus
de celle de la gravité il faudrait
plutôt me soulever
[Musique]
intéressant non vous n'avez exercé
aucune force de propulsion et pourtant
j'ai filé trois vers le sol c'est la
terre qui m'a attirée
pour voir s'il est attiré dans le fond
non ça c'est Archimède on nous confond
parfois on
l'emmène ta chatte
c'est forcément en rapport avec mon père
il faut l'aider
monsieur
pour les premières balles
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon nous sommes à l'abri dans
cette ruelle merci miroir
parce que à votre avis il fait quoi aux
gens qui s'enfuient pendant qu'il est
aux toilettes oh je sais il es-tu c'est
ça bravo super Einstein bon monsieur
Newton qu'est-ce que vous faites là vous
vivez pas en Angleterre si mais je suis
venu ici pour réfléchir au calme à une
nouvelle théorie et prendre un peu de
vacances ce sont clairement les pires
vacances de ma vie je suis un grand
scientifique très respecté de mon pays
savez-vous comment j'ai découvert la
théorie de la gravitation universelle je
marchais sous un arbre construit
la buse n'est pas loin une poire mais
tombée sur la tête
une poire mais dans les livres vous êtes
toujours dit que j'ai toujours été
passionné par les sciences depuis que je
suis haut comme trois chatons qu'on
aurait mis les uns sur les autres et
j'étais très mignon monsieur Newton
auriez-vous rencontré un autre
scientifique tout à fait voyez-vous un
certain docteur Simon m'a approché pour
en savoir plus sur une de mes théories
abandonnées sur l'infiniment moyen et
s'il y avait quelque chose entre
l'infiniment grand et l'infiniment petit
ce n'est tout petit migrants ni fini ni
infini ni passer ni présent nimou ni dur
ni froid ni chaud ni bon merci on a
compris tu m'étonnes
mais pourquoi mon père s'est intéressé à
ça ça m'a fait plaisir de parler avec
quelqu'un qui me comprenait et ensuite
il m'a volé mon carnet et il a disparu
et il a dit quelque chose avant de
partir genre allez salut je vais aller à
ok cool il a précisé qu'il partait chez
les Mayas pour y déposer une relique les
maillards une relique oui une relique
qui contient
votre Isaac Newton vient de se faire
buter par la hache de la buse mais la
buse tu abuses on a pas de signal
vous avez dit qu'on ne tuez pas tant
d'entre nous disait pas pomme j'ai dit
pomme c'est logique on ne peut pas lui
reprocher ça merci mais c'est quoi cette
histoire mon père a déposé une relique
chez les Mayas j'ai la trace d'un
passage du docteur Simon dans la
civilisation maya en l'an 1524
maintenant donnez-moi mes 8000 pièces
vous savez ce que je fais aujourd'hui
bien sûr on va vous payer attendez ne
bougez pas surtout je les cherche je
cherche et non toi
[Musique]
nous voici dans le sud du Mexique en
1524 la température extérieure est très
précisément de 29 degrés centigrade la
faune sauvage se compose d'insectes de
la mare vous aussi ça vous fait un truc
bizarre dans les intestins le voyage
dans le temps non ça c'est l'eau que tu
as bu dans la taverne et tu pourras pas
dire qu'on t'a pas prévenu qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé la buse il faisait
nuit au rappeler préparer une vieille
pièce je vais piller tout le monde et je
reviens
nickel on vient de lâcher un pirate
sanguinaire chez Maya mais où peut bien
être le docteur Simon que va-t-il
arriver à nos héros et qu'en est-il de
cette drôle de relique tout ça je le
sais vous aimeriez bien être à ma place
rendez vous au prochain épisode de
l'épopée temporaire
[Musique]
grande aventure les appelle
nos héros sont en terre Mayas au milieu
d'une végétation luxuriante et dans une
chaleur étouffante à la recherche du
docteur Simon et d'une prétendue relique
et comme moultz explorateur vous le
confirmeront les aventures à l'étranger
commencent bien souvent par un problème
d'un test
Thomas c'est pas moi
Elliott peut-être je n'ai pas d'orifice
qui permet de produire ce son bon moment
pour toi nous on t'attend ici ça vient
pas de moi vous savez quoi ça m'énerve
ces accusations j'ai besoin d'un moment
tout seul pour voilà réfléchir à un plan
pour récupérer la relique de ton père
juste derrière les buissons là les
buissons de la réflexion que je reviens
iris c'est étrange je ne t'ai jamais vu
à sourire ce besoin humain que
représente l'évacuation des déchets
parce que je suis une princesse Eliott
tenez voici les clés Aliénor regarde
Thomas il y a ah oui c'est vrai il fait
caca vous ne prenez pas les clés mais on
s'en fout tes clés à la con tu vois bien
qu'on est plus enfermé dans un bateau
où sommes-nous désormais quelle est
cette forêt luxurieuse est-ce le paradis
perdons battant garde tes clés là et
donne-nous la machine à voyager dans le
temps
si ça peut me permettre de récupérer mon
royaume mais [ __ ] il faut toujours
qu'elle disparaisse
je détecte d'autres êtres humains
certainement des Mayas ne vous
approchons pas ils sont trop nombreux
mais ils sont en train de l'enlever
c'est trop dangereux pour le moment on
le laisse se faire trucider on le laisse
se faire préciser non bien sûr que non
pardon je n'avais pas compris que le
temps aduisait la réponse suivant
ok les gars vous comptez faire quoi avec
moi au juste là je trouve que c'est
important mais j'ai un peu peur que j'ai
oh une pyramide d'accord on va à la
pierre ok on va à la pyramide [ __ ]
c'est toujours quand j'ai besoin d'un
traducteur robot du futur qui n'a jamais
vous allez faire quoi de moi
regardez ils emmènent Thomas en haut de
la pyramide
maintenant c'est possible
on s'approche il faut le sauver la
cérémonie commence
je peux pas regarder je ferme les yeux
c'est trop cruel il soulève Thomas
devant la faune et le temps d’about de
bras j'ai pas fermé les yeux pour que tu
me décrives précisément la mort de mon
ex très bien mode silencieux activé
qu'est-ce qui se passe
fin du mode silencieux je décris ou je
décris pas tant pis j'ouvre les yeux
[Applaudissements]
ils ont l'air totalement pacifiques en
fait
Elliott on a peut-être une chance
d'autres étrangers
bienvenue vous voulez des guilis aussi
nous sommes ici pour libérer notre ami
Thomas il est pas prisonnier on devait
juste faire la cérémonie des chatouilles
maintenant que c'est fait nous avons
satisfait les dieux et donc chocolat
chaud merci
cacao et pendant qu'il le touille on lui
fait des chatouilles
presque aussi bon que mon café je suis
preneur de la recette vraiment c'est pas
votre addition de faire des sacrifices
humains avant oui avant il y a 200 ans
nos ancêtres étaient complètement fous
ils sacrifiait des vierges pour les
dieux tout ça mais entre temps on a
découvert le cacao ça nous a tous
détendu et maintenant ces chatouilles au
chocolat chaud aujourd'hui on est
pacifique hein c'est fini cette violence
d'ailleurs comment peut-on vous aider
étranger je suis un robot qui vient du
futur et voici Thomas du 20e siècle nous
sommes ici pour chercher une relique que
l'inventeur de la machine à voyagé dans
le temps vous a sûrement confié comme ça
mais vous vous croyez va crois déjà une
bonne trentaine de Dieu dont le dieu
chasseur d'oposom alors des gens qui
voyagent dans le temps franchement c'est
pas dingue d'ailleurs on a eu la visite
d'un dieu blanc pas plus tard que ce
matin
bon car il a disparu comme par magie il
nous a donné une relique à protéger
comme la prunelle de nos yeux on l'a
enfouis tout le temps avec des pièges
des gardes des caïmans on adore les
cailloux regard
ez ils arrivent dans des
énormes préparer du cacao pour les
visiteurs ce qu'ils appellent visiteurs
semble être des conquistadors cool ils
vont nous massacrer et s'emparer du pays
cool quoi comment ils sont beaux les
nouveaux visiteurs assis sur leur chien
géant et tout ils ont des bâtons qui
font du bruit et des éclairs regarde
Capou des cavaliers avec des fusils
comme c'est horrible
ami Maya ces hommes sont mauvais et
dangereux ils sont là pour s'emparer de
vos terres
soyez pas parano comme ça descendons les
accueillir vite le cacao et les
gaufrettes
[Musique]
voici du cacao et des petites gaufrettes
croustillantes super bonne tiens rigole
toi
[Musique]
Royaume d'Espagne
la traduction mais c'est obligé l'accent
pourri je n'aime pas cet homme je lui
fais un accent pourri
combien de tigre
mais c'est qui lui avait oublié
j'adore ce voyage bien joué la bûche
merci tu nous as sauvé sans toi c'était
la fin c'est bizarre ce qui s'est passé
j'avais ni envie de vous demander de
l'argent ni envie de vous tuer juste
envie de vous aider la buse c'est parce
qu'on est devenu des amis des amis où tu
étais la buse oh mais tes amis j'ai vécu
une aventure incroyable je suis parti à
la recherche d'un trésor j'ai vu ce
temple la pyramide ouais ça je suis
entré dedans et puis je suis venu mon
instinct de pirate il y avait des
énigmes à résoudre genre de statut
presque identique mais qui pouvait
bouger il semble qu'il fallait faire une
combinaison de mouvement et alors j'ai
tout cassé
je suis passé oh non il a cassé nos
pièges après il y avait un long corridor
qui manquait des dalles et il y avait
des flèches empoisonnées qui sortaient
des murs et il semblait qu'il y avait un
chemin précis à suivre
je suis arrivé devant une porte en métal
forgée avec des taxes chiffres on aurait
dit une suite de nombres et tu as tout
cassé non j'ai mis les chiffres dans un
ordre précis c'était la suite de
Fibonacci quelqu'un me l'avait expliqué
avant que je le tue mais ça veut dire
que tu as trouvé la relique de mon père
enfin le
trésoreau
je me souviens c'était un jouet que
j'avais quand j'étais petite c'est un
calendrier rond que mon père m'avait
donné pour apprendre le système solaire
est-ce qu'on s'en irait pas parce qu'il
y a les cavaliers qui débarquent encore
il y a 10 mois qui a un indice sur cet
objet d'après mes capteurs le calendrier
possède une balise donnant des
coordonnées temporelle divisé en trois
parties il nous manque deux valises et
où est-ce qu'on trouve ça
adore son
petit bon mes calculs m'indique où se
trouve la seconde balise
on peut s'y rendre maintenant
je pense que ta force sera plus utile au
Maya qui vont devoir
notre destination semble très dangereuse
une aide puissante ne serait pas de
refus bon d'accord la buse tu viens avec
nous
vous cache pas que les prochaines
semaines risquent d'être difficile alors
tenez bon
on va faire ce qu'on sait faire de mieux
on fait des et ça nous
les dieux sont ravis et on se fait des
amis
OK et juste comme ça si vous offre des
couvertures refusez-les
le saviez-vous les envahisseurs
européens n'ont pas hésité à donner des
couvertures contaminées par la petite
vérole pour déchimer les populations
d'Amérique l'épopée temporelle ce n'est
pas que du divertissement c'est aussi de
la culture sauf les petites gaufrettes
ça les Mayas ils n'en avaient pas à la
semaine prochaine pour découvrir leur
nouvelle destination